comme ils ramènent c'est notre
principale culture
ce les oignons temps avait d ailleurs à
ramasser les ramasser ça commence avec
une combine qui est l'eau
ça vous a fait des arrêts dt
combien vous en avez comme ça 450 mais
l'un d'eux un demi million de plants
devant nous et vous les vendez ou ses
laitues l'heure principalement ils
avaient précédement homard au canada les
gros chats et chiens d'aluminé
d'alimentation les grossistes
il est qu'ils sont une place au marché
central convient en gros pour les
clients
par rapport aux dernières années est-ce
que 2015 va être quand même malgré tout
une bonne on voit sa fin de saison
dernière
la dernière école quand on fait le bilan
de la saison et c'est parti pour être un
red bull et avec le dollar canadien qui
boit comme ça parce que ça vous êtes
vous un rôle encore plus aux états unis
ça nous aide beaucoup
au canada il perdu beaucoup trop de
l'étude de produisent après quatre shows
soviétique
il se produit beaucoup trop de pour la
canadien
mccain s'était conclue par mon père dans
l'histoire des années et peut-être
fantaisie forte king il faisait chaud de
la machinerie du rhin du bas rhin
on est en pleine campagne électorale des
producteurs maraîchers comme vous quand
vous regardez une campagne s'arrête
qu'est-ce que de quoi vous avez besoin
vous avez les politiciens fédéraux
on n'a pas le temps de s'en occuper non
mais je dis vos demandes
vous avez des travailleurs étrangers si
vous avez beaucoup de mexicains est-ce
que ce que des choses qui pourraient
améliorer pour vous faciliter la vie
baky qui arrêtent de nous et des
d'essayer de nous mettre des bâtons dans
les roues pour les travailleurs
étrangers
comme quoi les exigences danané soucier
plus difficile pour avoir des
travailleurs étrangers au québec et en
europe
quand vous étiez plus jeune vous c'est
votre père ici il n'avait pas trahi et
étrangers pour que ça fonctionne et que
ça fonctionne plus bonne question c'est
quoi la mentalité des gens que change
est fort probable aujourd'hui des jeunes
créateurs de toutes façons vous en
trouvez pas des jeunes qui sont prêts à
venir ramasser des laitues ou des
selleries l'humilier en faisant deux
parfums proportions vous iriez là au
village nom partout non nos pauvres s'il
vient ni bien dans une semaine
quatre jours un jour de semaine pourrait
se prononcer il faudra jouer une tonne
d'eau puis avec les mecs qu'elle voulait
traiter lien oui on est et reste les
mexicains ont les traits de pareils
comme garant un québécois que le
travailleur c'est qu'ici tout le monde
au minimum tout le monde tout le monde
est traité de n'importe quelle
nationalité sont heurtés pareil
c'est ce qui fait chaud c'est doit
maintenant à carhaix
à ce qu'ils reviennent d'année en année
vous travaillez titre avait retranché
jeudi pour ça revienne
est ce que les québécois ici mange plus
de produits québécois qui pose d'un
gauche depuis quelques années
et eux plus de campagnes manger québec
ça nous aide beaucoup et c'est sûr que
ça nous paraît est-ce que c'est plus
facile quand on devient de plus en plus
gros aujourd'hui aux quatre petits l'été
des problèmes catégorie le nommer cet
immense vous avez racheté une terre à
côté
est ce que c'est une tendance du marché
de ces fonds dans d'autres c'est rendu
que les le petit et de plus en plus de
misère avec la paperasse rio et
logistique de sophie lillie normes qui
tout qu'est-ce qui nous demandent la
saur pour sa belle laperne faute je
produise sa part entre volume c'est quoi
votre cauchemar au cours des cauchemars
et des lieux depuis 2 propose ce petit
cours d'eau en février puis perdre et
combien super deschamps la seconde y est
âgé entre le titan totalement demi
million de têtes de l'étude au bout de
ligne ça peut faire une arme normalement
d'argent 2012 on était cinq cents heures
de produits les limiers sont éteints en
2012 tout a grêlé tout au complet fini
tout rose est finie que je fais de sang
le jour au pas le coeur à 12 millions
on peut cultiver plus tard par rapport
au mois de septembre mais kezman mois
d'août change votre production
voudraient quand on est une douce quinze
jours plus tard que l'eau 1960 quoi 60
et j'allais vous rythme de rendre plus
tard à manger vous autant qu'avant mon
amant jouer à la marque aux trois bandes
de fraîcheur
par rapport aux salades le prix du
céleri ctu plus stable ça dépend des
périodes de cha cha cun légumes chaque
variété de légumes des tendances les
variations pris le second set à des
procédés je dirais que oui à malte
active puis le mépris stabilise
là qu'est ce qu'ils font et ce qu'ils
font le trajet en train de récolter du
céleri mètres en bois et la vie il avait
mis en boîte classique prête pour le
marché de marché ça sort quinze sait à
quel moment je le retrouve sur les
tablettes de bon supermarché
tout dépend la main 6 à bord dans des
chaînes de magasins
ça va être plus long ça peut prendre
trois ou quatre cinq jours si certains
bourdin fruiterie d'un libre marché peut
y avoir de demain
ces dames âgées à télé on sortira pas
mais sa sellerie waouf on peut faire
pareil caisse à 2015 de cédric ça donne
le goût de manger en faveur des droits
humains
parce que bon
non pour moi
et du québec apple 1
taj et rien d'autre
c'est bon comme métier vous aurez beau
métier sap r oui mais ça c'est comme
n'importe quel métier foot est une
passion vous changera pas nos on ait
rencontré votre fils qui vont faire ceux
qui vont reprendre quatre garçons un
moment de l'été ces trois gars sont à
l'eau sont plus jeunes et donc la relève
ici c'est un problème qui se posait
hall aux gens s'ils veulent le problème
la relève est assurée